THAT HALF OF MILLENNIALS
DISTRESS CAPITALISM.
70% OF MILLENNIALS BE WILLING TO
VOTE FOR A SOCIALIST.
IF YOU WANT SHOCKED BY THIS,
IT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE SEEN IT
BEFORE.
POLLS LIKE THIS APPEAR TO BE
EVERYWHERE ALL OF A SUDDEN.
THAT OUGHT TO SCARE YOU.
IT'S TAKING THIS 250 YEARS TO
BUILD THIS COUNTRY.
WE CAN WRECK IT IN A SINGLE
GENERATION.
AT THIS RATE, WE WILL.
POLLS LIKE THIS PREDICT A
LOOMING DISASTER.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT THAT, WE
NEED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT HAS
GONE WRONG.
YOU OFTEN HEAR IT SAID THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE SUPPORT SOCIALISM
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
BRAINWASHED BY THEIR PROFESSORS.
OF COURSE, THERE IS TRUTH TO
THAT.
IF YOU'VE GOT KIDS IN COLLEGE,
WE LET THE MOST VITAL JOB IN
AMERICA, EDUCATING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CITIZENS, TO SOME
OF THE MOST MEDIOCRE PEOPLE IN
SOCIETY.
THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
WE NEED TO FIX IT.
BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT'S NOT
THE MAIN PROBLEM.
THE MAIN PROBLEM, THE REASON
THAT CAPITALISM INCREASINGLY IS
DISCREDITED AND SOCIALISM IS
INCREASINGLY POPULAR, IS THAT
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS MAKING
YOUNG PEOPLE POOR.
GO TO COLLEGE, YOU'LL BE
SUCCESSFUL IF YOU DO.
BUT TOO OFTEN, THAT ADVICE IS
OUTDATED, IF NOT AN UTTER LIE.
HUGE NUMBERS OF OUR KIDS WIND UP
IN IMPOVERISHED BY THE
EXPERIENCE OF COLLEGE, THEIR
DREAMS AFFORDED FOREVER.
THE REASON FOR THAT IS DEBT.
45 MILLION AMERICANS NOW LABOR
UNDER STUDENT LOANS BY THE
AVERAGE DEBT BURDEN IS $37,000
PER PERSON.
THAT'S THE PRICE OF A BRAND-NEW
CAR.
IMAGINE STARTING YOUR FIRST JOB
WITH THAT HANGING OVER YOU.
KEEP IN MIND, COLLEGE DEBT ISN'T
LIKE ORDINARY DEBT THANKS TO
WELL-FUNDED LOBBYING CAMPAIGNS,
STUDENT LOANS CANNOT BE ERASED
BY BANKRUPTCY.
THEY LAST FOREVER.
MANY OF TODAY'S COLLEGE FRESHMEN
CAN EXPECT TO SPEND THEIR
WORKING LIVES INTEREST ON LOANS
IN THE END THAT DIDN'T HELP THEM
AT ALL.
NO WONDER YOUNG PEOPLE AREN'T
GETTING MARRIED OR BUYING HOMES
OR HAVING CHILDREN.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO.
AND NO WONDER SO MANY OF THEM
SUPPORT BERNIE SANDERS AND
LISBETH WARREN.
IF THIS IS CAPITALISM, THEY
DON'T WANT ANY PART OF IT.
THE IRONY, OF COURSE, IS THE
ONLY PEOPLE BENEFITING FROM THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM ARE ON THE FAR
LEFT, THE COLLEGE PRESIDENTS
WITH MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
SALARIES.
THE AUTHORITARIAN UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE SUDDENLY
UBIQUITOUS DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION OFFICES.
THE TENURED PRESSERS DOWN THE
PROFESSORS OF NONBINARY FEMINIST
POETRY AND OTHER FAKE ACADEMIC
DISCIPLINES.
WITHOUT QUESTION THE LEAST
IMPRESSIVE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND YET THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES
COMING OUT AHEAD OF THE DEAL.
THEY ARE FEASTING ON OUR
CHILDREN'S DEBT.
AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF
AMERICANS ENSLAVED TO INTEREST
PAYMENTS SO THAT A SMALL NUMBER
OF LEFT-WING ACADEMICS CAN HAVE
LIFETIME EMPLOYMENT MAKING THIS
COUNTRY WORSE.
THAT'S THE ARRANGEMENT WE'VE
STRUCK.
AND FOR THE REST OF US?
SOCIALISM FOR THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO GET OUT OF IT IN
REACTION TO IT.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A BETTER WAY
TO DO THINGS.
SOME ON THE LEFT PROPOSE FOR
GIVING STUDENT LOANS ENTIRELY,
WHICH IS TO SAY STICKING
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS WITH THE BILL
FOR ALL OF THIS.
IF THERE IS ONE THING THAT CAN
MAKE A TERRIBLE SITUATION EVEN
WORSE, IT'S THAT.
TAXPAYERS DIDN'T CAUSE THIS
PROBLEM HERE THEY SHOULDN'T BE
PUNISHED ANYMORE THAN THEY
ALREADY HAVE BEEN.
THE CORRUPT HIGHER EDUCATION
ESTABLISHMENT CONCOCTED THIS
SCAM.
THEY SHOULD PAY TO FIX IT.
HARVARD'S ENDOWMENT IS
$40 BILLION.
YALE'S ENDOWMENT IS 30 BILLION.
LET'S START THERE.
WHAT'S CLEAR IS WE NEED TO MOVE
THE CRASHING FINANCIAL BURDEN OF
STUDENT DEBT OFF THE SHOULDERS
OF MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES AND
22-YEAR-OLDS AND BACK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GOTTEN RICH FROM
IT.
THAT'S AN IDEA THAT EVERY
SENSIBLE PERSON CAN SUPPORT.
IN FACT, THERE'S A BIG POLITICAL
PAYOFF OR ANY POLITICIAN WISE
ENOUGH TO ADOPT IT.
THE CANDIDATE THAT PROMISES
COLLEGES TO EASE THE STUDENT
LOAN BURDEN WITHOUT QUESTION
WILL BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
IN SAMUEL HAS BEEN A GREAT DEAL
OF TIME IN ACADEMIC AMERICA.
A FORMER SUPREME COURT CLERK
AMONG OTHER THINGS BUT THANK YOU
FOR COMING ON.
BECAUSE A SMALL GROUP OF GREEDY,